nobody pull a hamstring the thing about
time travel I can't believe I made a
whole movie with this thing I look
cooler doesn't feel cool but if it looks
cool as ice you have any idea what's
coursing through my veins right now Sun
yawns yes Orange seven we are getting
double team aren't we
[Music]
you have to deal with here 10 years of
it Oh clear which way oh you say
something I said I want to call my eyes
out but unfortunately we're doing it
good cuz I already saw the awfulness
will you focus on focus this pretty
place is about to get are gonna fight
real quick by a bunch of freaking elves
do you know you know I saw all these
people who died so this is a little bit
difficult for me ok so once you reach
down deep inside and try and find a
small of humanity just omit it they give
me the thing you're embarrassing all
right which way you don't know you used
to freaking live here for 1500 years not
forever I think we had dead we are so so
dead being able to do this new version
of Thor it's hugely liberating and fun
we had a big set of fat suit which I
think was sort of 60 or 70 pounds
it was the hottest I've ever been I mean
amazing and we had to the beard the hair
and had these things that go in the
mouth that kind of plump out my cheeks a
bit which sort of had a little effect on
the voice as well but probably eating
the good boy it was it was a different
fall I'm a tall 22 years old the one ask
God and I'll Oxford that we're shooting
a superhero film and here's one of those
recognisable superheroes but he's just
turned into a new character what Chris
does with that character and how it just
kind of heads this shift his excitement
was really palpable
he had been playing the character for a
while and really wanted to find
something new
he has such dexterity as a talent he's
incredibly funny he is just really
lovely energy is he asleep no no I'm
pretty sure he's dead I actually think
that in some weird and it is a very
emotional thing but some weird twisted
up fateful way this character who you
know has searched her whole life for a
purpose actually finds her purpose and
it's like this amazing super emotional
beautiful thing you know I don't judge
people in their worst mistakes
[Music]
maybe you sure you didn't
I feel very fortunate it's been an
incredible gift as an actor to be able
to come back to a character that says
complex is Natasha I think there's a
kind of a lot to explore there and that
is so exciting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
give me that grab a little
what the hell is this Friday what are
they firing at something just entered
the upper atmosphere
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dampers we need an assist here
[Music]
[Music]
hi I'm Peter Parker hey Peter Parker you
got something for me
[Applause]
don't worry she's got chills
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I knew right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in heaven
[Music]
this is the fight of our lives we are
getting the whole team right Oh God it's
tough regular sized man hey guys let's
do it
is that everyone you wanted more
are you crying this is my destiny
Avengers Assemble
[Applause]
[Music]
no no give me that you have the little
one
[Music]
[Music]